vacciner massivement pour rattraper un
retard important c'est l'objectif
principal de l'exécutif avec l'ouverture
de ce vaccinodromes au stade de france
dix mille doses par semaine doivent être
administrés ici même
et puisque la france et le département
manque de doses il faut trouver ces
fameuses dos quitte à piocher dans les
communes environnantes
l'exemple de la ville de rosny sous bois
dans le 93 parle de lui même un centre a
ouvert ses portes le 23 mars dernier
avec l'objectif de vacciner 500
personnes par semaine puis rapidement de
passer à 1750 doses par semaine un échec
les livraisons un s'amenuisant le centre
a reçu 378 doses à cette semaine et 200
sont attendus pour la semaine d'après
même son de cloche du côté de ce temps
où le maire de la ville montent au
créneau
on a entendu depuis maintenant depuis
depuis lundi des retards de livraison de
livraison qui n'ont pas pu être honorées
et visiblement il ya un lien il ya un
lien avec justement l'ouverture depuis
maintenant mardi du centre de
vaccination du stade de france voilà
donc je pense qu'il faut être très très
vigilant parce que forcément ça va avoir
des conséquences sur un nombre encore
encore réduit de vacciner en
seine-saint-denis et pour les zones
rurales de l'hexagone c'est un problème
majeur de logistique qui vient s'ajouter
à cette pénurie de doses notamment pour
les personnes âgées qui ne peuvent se
permettre bien souvent de faire 30
minutes de trajet pour se faire vacciner
ou bien de faire des queues à rallonge
comme ici même ou un stade de france le
gouvernement n'entend pas à délaisser
les zones rurales qui représente 38% de
la population française
les élus locaux insistent sur la
nécessité de décentraliser et la
possibilité pour les maires préfets et
sous préfets de faire le lien avec
l'état et les territoires
la mise en place de ces vaccinodromes
marque un pas de plus vers le tropisme
urbain dont fait preuve le gouvernement
on privilégie des solutions de
concentration obligeant les gens qui
habitent loin de ces centres à une
mobilité forcée alors qu'on pourrait
mettre en place d'autres solutions
l'important est de simplifier la vie des
gens pour ne pas les obliger à faire des
kilomètres inutiles alors qu'une
solution locale est possible
on demande la même attention pour la
population rurale que pour la population
urbaine l'ensemble du territoire est
concerné par cette nouvelle donne que
l'exécutif n'avait pas forcément
anticipé car alimenter ses vaccinodromes
géant pourrait risquer une pénurie d'eau
dans les petits centres de vaccination
et pourrait entraîner indirectement leur
fermeture
les annulations de rendez-vous
s'accumulent comme à rosny sous bois par
exemple et la compréhension 9 heures
parmi les habitants des communes les
plus reculées
celle de seine-saint-denis où d'ailleurs
sur le territoire